A space that is new in concept
to Harvard and new in design
as well is the i-lab
adjacent to the Business
School on the Boston
side of the river.
It's a space that is intended
to be for all of Harvard,
and it's a space that's designed
for invention, creativity,
entrepreneurship, for
people to come together
to pursue bringing ideas
into the public realm,
either commercial or nonprofit,
to seek the advice of venture
capitalists and intellectual
property lawyers who
come and consult, and
offer classes, and offer
consultations to groups of
student who join together
to advance their ideas
and bring them into a form
where they can make a
difference in the world.
It's a very open space
that can be reconfigured
in a variety of ways.
It's a space that's available
day and night to individuals
who wish to take advantage
of these opportunities
to bring their
ideas to a new form.
And I think it's a
space that has marked
a departure from Harvard into a
realm of entrepreneurship that
wasn't present here
in the same dimensions
that the i-lab has enabled
and fostered over the years
since it came together.
So I love the one
Harvard part about it.
I love the collaborative space,
the idea of using our marvelous
diversity of individuals
to strengthen one another's
ideas and possibilities,
and I love
the idea of the kind of impact
that the organizations that
have begun there have been able
to have already on the world
and will continue to
have on the world.